demonstrators have been venting their
anger inside banks across Lebanon they
want access to their money banking
restrictions were imposed when
anti-government protests began in
mid-october banks are limiting access to
withdrawals of dollars and imposed caps
on the Lebanese pound to the informal
controls on capital are affecting many
some customers have resorted to violence
I was obliged to reduce the cost to
today to the minimum I moved my my
office working from from home because I
cannot pay any more expensive it
extended the balance of the project so
now let's say I'm having five millions
each week I have to divide the to three
project including my personal my
personal expenses but bankers say they
had little choice to manage the lack of
cash between September and November
during those three months deposits in
the banking sectors declined by 10
billion dollars and the balance which is
about 50% to 55% of this amount was cash
withdrawals by citizens and companies
but many Lebanese are accusing banks of
robbing them from their savings because
they are now forced to deal in Lebanese
pounds the flow of money out of Lebanon
and the lack of foreign currency
deposits created a shortage of dollars
that's affected the Lebanese pound which
lost at least 50% of its value on the
black market over the past three months
and the crisis of confidence in the
banking sector is not the only problem
Lebanon has been without a government
since prime minister saddle Harry Lee
resigned in October during widespread
protests against the political elite
over corruption and the cost of living
have clear demand by the banking sector
former government that will bring back
trust into the country into the
political class and can actually
implement some of the reforms needed to
unlock funds and bring in fresh
US dollars into the country in recent
weeks protests against Lebanon's leaders
have become smaller in size when
compared to the early days of the
uprising but demonstrators are promising
to return as warnings of a financial
collapse grow louder Sarah Hodor al
Jazeera Beirut